travailler autour de la table je vous ai
fait subir beaucoup beaucoup de choses
regardez tout ce que j'ai fait subir à
ces personnes qui sont là qui
travaillent tous les jours pourrait
commencer à sortir parce que vous allez
pouvoir vous mangez regardez ça venait
avec moi crise il a regardé on se
retrouve dehors pour la vengeance est
parti à l'est on y va
[Musique]
je vais bien
mais pareil il faut que je me mette mes
mains d'une certaine façon méritoire se
venger je vous le dis alors je sais pas
du tout est-ce qu'on peut m'expliquer
comment je te remettes vas-y aminé
madani et mines et mathieu tu peux me
dire quand à ercis et 1000mercis
commente ailleurs à un bouddha au bout
d'un bâton pour sa poche rené fallet les
coudes dans les poches tout de suite pas
garder leurs billets d'euro millions
c'est peut-être le gagnant celui-là
dockers cgt christophe carrière qui me
rend fier pour mon anniversaire merci
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je passe
mon téléphone il est parti d'accord et
puis ça va
vu l'équipe j'y crois pas trop attention
ils doivent se met tous mais ils sont
très proches la wii
non mais on va viser c'est parce que
j'ai déjà les pieds mouillés
non c'est bon merci merci c'est bon
alors et donc je me mets comme ça je me
mets comme ça un essai voir ça marche
d'abord mais surtout message on prend le
micro données et aux détenus
[Applaudissements]
alors à tous en même temps soyez
discipliné tout fait soyez dissiper le
flou
et toi
attention attention y'a série mon
attention
non
des comics et des grenades
émotion et passion jean michel maire
jean luc lemoine vous vous avancez n'ont
volé mais après c'est fini dans leurs
premières trompa mercredi pas partie la
table dans l'au delà
non non non non
[Applaudissements]
jean-claude ballons jaunes au drame à
l'eau dans les îles aux quatre anneaux
mais enfin ça m'emmerde trois tournois y
va je vais manger du sur marc kravetz
que je l'aimais beaucoup
attention c'est parti mon verre travaux
chéri on regarde et je vais mettre un
ballon aussi bertrand séjour à perdre je
sais mais c'est clair qu'on aime bien le
long du corps
huawei bras dont jean-luc envoie mes
samia meziane journée je me fous chéri
[Applaudissements]
il a gagné